call of duty modern warfare 2 comes out
real soon and activision just dropped
some big details for the game like war
zone 2's release date as well as some
new multiplayer changes
from dolphin diving to some brand new
maps here's everything we know so far
about call of duty modern warfare 2.
activision dropped a huge multiplayer
and warzone 2.0 reveal on all of us and
the setup is wicked maybe even embracing
a little bit of battlefield i mean i
swear i saw a drone try its best jeep
stuff impersonation against a helicopter
right wasn't just me multiplayer is
bringing a bunch of new changes both in
the forms of gameplay graphics as well
as game modes and live service updates
modern warfare 2 and zone 2 will have
separate release dates on october 26th
and november 16th but the story universe
across the two will remain connected
there's also gonna be a lot of new
mechanics like amphibious assault water
itself is like actually a whole thing in
modern warfare 2 seriously dealing and
interacting with water is part of the
new gameplay features and movement
tactics which include straight up
swimming diving and underwater combat so
let's talk game modes during the next
reveal we got to see a little look on a
couple of game modes like invasion and
prisoner rescue
invasion is basically ground war with ai
teammates internally referred to as the
quote shipment of ground war which
damn i don't even know what that means
to be honest but it sounds nuts it's a
20v20 mode with 20 ai bots on each team
as well and it's an interesting setup
because the mode is referred to as being
more chill with play styles varying like
like up to you you can pop on a rooftop
and camp out with a sniper or you can
grab your favorite shotgun to try to
clear out a few rooms fascinatingly the
ai are meant to be the standout feature
of the game mode and don't worry though
you won't see any bots if you're not a
fan of them in other core game modes
like domination or search and destroy
next up we've got prisoner rescue
prisoner rescue has hostages and it is
up to you to get them out alive or to
defend them at all costs from extraction
there are no respawns one shot one
opportunity mom spaghetti eminem lose
yourself type moment here y'all the mode
is round based and there are only two
prisoners if you pick up the prisoner
you are somewhat vulnerable because you
can only fight with either a pistol or
your fist however to help with balance
the escort team will have advantages
like a radar sweep for enemy callouts as
well as removing the mark indicator off
the prisoner meaning that the defending
team won't be able to see where the
prisoners are located mid extraction so
let's turn over to maps during the cod
next showcase there was a clear split
and design philosophy between
competitive small maps and larger ones
from larger maps with several points of
interest to smaller tighter and faster
engagements you will see in 6v6 based
maps now we got to see two of them there
was a 6v6 map in mercado los alamos a
little street market in a historic
section of mexico the rumor is there's a
crap ton of drugs being smuggled and
authorities want to seize them and
according to the dev there's a slight
warning be wary of this map during the
beta y'all cause it plays fast
serif bay is a battle map located in the
southern coast and has all the aesthetic
of a small fishing town perfect for that
water-based gameplay i mentioned earlier
the map shifts dramatically from the
waters as you move into town where
suddenly engagements become cluttered in
an urban area with plenty of rooftops
and ledges to hang from as well allowing
for some cool parkour as you traverse to
your next kill
battle maps now encompass a wide variety
of modes with ground war just being one
of them
warzone 2.0 is going back to its roots
but with an all-new map in alamarza
vehicles have a new physics model which
means different handling depending on
what vehicles you use there's also a
cool implementation of destruction one
thing i want to try out is popping some
tires to mess with an enemy driver
before snagging a kill or two there's a
completely new circle mechanic in
warzone 2.0 as well instead of having
one giant circle across the map that
slowly shrinks over the course of the
match there are gonna be multiple
circles that would isolate themselves
from each other before eventually
traveling to a final point where the
circles merge kind of makes me think of
a tournament bracket you know you clear
out the opponents within your circle
first before meeting up with the last
players standing from their own circles
for a final showdown
there are also strongholds which are
complete with ai enemies into war zone
2.0 which i'm not sure how fans will
feel about the ai i mean fortnite does
it pretty well all things considered so
there may be something here the main
incentive to fight in a stronghold
though is for that good sweet loot the
ai fortified strongholds will have some
excellent gear so if you manage to
survive and not make too much noise and
avoid other players it may have been
worth the risk
arriving alongside warzone 2.0 we have
dmz which is an extraction mode located
on the same warzone 2.0 map al-mazra the
rumors were this was going to be cod's
escape from tarkov mode but the priority
on player choice on what you want to do
go loud go quiet or just avoid as many
players as possible and explore the map
there wasn't a lot revealed and more
will be shared at a later time now
there's a new gunsmith as well which cod
recently dropped the trailer for it
allows players to swap between weapons
while offering a bunch of customization
and an overhaul to how weapons are
classified weapons platforms are meant
to streamline progression and create
attachment pools according to the cod
blog operators will receive every base
weapons platform from each manufacturer
on their military rank progression
journey the first weapon unlocked on a
weapons platform will be known by its
receiver the core of a weapon that
determines its primary use and strengths
so take an m4 the manufacturer's tempest
armaments and it has an assault rifle
classification after heading into the
gunsmith you will see the receiver
attachment an addition of slots for
muzzles barrels mags and other parts
this receiver is what allows you to
completely change the weapon into
something new when building a loadout
while retaining the same unlocked
attachments and having the new weapon
live in the same weapons platform so
like you can upgrade a weapon beyond its
class and turn an assault rifle into an
smg
dmr or even an lmg attachment unlocks
are shared between weapons platforms
where depending on the attachment it's
either unlocked for all weapons within
that platform or all weapons in the
entire game this means less
repetitiveness and more reasonable
challenges to unlock attachments and
camo there is also a firing range so you
can test out your creation we'll
definitely be diving into what we can
make maybe some cool frankenstein
weapons that can break the meta i mean
we'll definitely be trying our best to
break the brain of jonathan ferguson for
some wicked expert reacts episodes in
the future with modern warfare 2 guns
and the gunsmith will be perfect for
that there's going to be a multi-tiered
launch with modern warfare 2 with the
campaign and multiplayer coming out
being followed by warzone 2.0 a few
weeks later we then also have the dmz
and then lastly raids as mentioned
before call of duty modern warfare 2
comes out on most platforms both last
gen and current gen that means xbox one
xbox series snx ps4 ps5 and pc users
will all get to play the game the
release date for modern warfare 2 is on
october 28th and is available for
pre-order right now at 59.99 on last
chance and 70 bucks for current gen
there are also deluxe and crosstrend
bundles available the open beta will be
available soon and those who pre-order a
digital edition of the game will
actually receive early access to the
campaign for up to a week and warzone
2.0 as always remains free
we got some serious cod fans in the
house at gamespot and a bunch of us will
be playing so sub to this channel follow
us on twitter for our cod takes i mean
cooking up right now i've got a live
stream with the gang as well as some
more expert reacts vids which will go
live on our channel every saturday
as for me personally i just whipped up a
deep dive into battlefield 2042 and if
redemption is even possible for that
game so be sure to pop in and check it
out until next time